[Narrator] Wow was that actually it for HTML?
Actually, yes, remember we only have 3 types of HTML elements.
The word element, which we just shot how to handle.
We call graphics.word; the tag element, which we also saw how to handle.
We check to make sure the tags match.
We call graphics begin tag and graphics end tag, and the Java script element.
Now, this is super tough, but it's not really HTML proper.
Here's what we're going to do: step 1, we'll interpret the Java script until we get a string.
Step 2, we'll just call graphics.word on that string.
Whatever they want us to print out, we will.
Now, we just need to know how to interpret Java script,
and then we'll be done with our web browser.
However, Java script is symantically richer than HTML,
which means it will be harder to interpret.
For example, Java script has arithmetic and HTML rarely has arithmetic.
Java script also has variables.
HTML rarely has variables, and we're going to have to deal with all of these things,
but we have to start somewhere so let's just start with arithmetic.
Suppose our input is 12 + 34.
We'll be given a parse tree that looks mostly like this,
but with some extra decorations.
Remember that our parse tree is actually more--it will look more like this for the leaves.
They're all tuples, but I'm abstracting away the tuples stuff just to show you the shape of it.
What we're going to do is just write a procedure, again, called interpret or Java script interpret,
that walks down the tree and computes values and returns them back up.
How do I figure out what this plus means?
Well, I'm going to call myself recursively.
How do I figure out what this times means?
Well, it's a binary operator so I'm going to figure out my left child.
That's 1, and figure out my right child that's 2, so 1*2 is 2.
I'll just bring that up, pass that up to my parent.
Now, I'll call myself recursively over here.
How do I figure out this times?
Well, this is a 3, and that's a 4, so together they make 12, so this whole thing is 14.
Our order was down this way, down that way, back up, down this way, all the way back up,
and that's how we're going to figure out Java script arithmetic.
Interpreting complicated languages in computer science is often called evaluation,
which is abbreviated to eval in many instances.
We're going to write an eval procedure for arithmetic expressions like this.
It will therefore be called evaluate expression.